[MUSIC PLAYING]
AARON ZEMACH: Everyone please
welcome to Google, Ben Ratliff.
Hi, Ben.
BEN RATLIFF: Thank you.
AARON ZEMACH: So
just to get started,
I was wondering
if you could talk
a little bit about your
history with music criticism,
how you got started in
reviewing music in your career.
BEN RATLIFF: I grew up in
a family of non-musicians.
But for one reason or
another, I was always
oriented toward listening
closely to music.
I don't know why, but I was.
And it just started
with whatever
was at hand, whatever
records we had in the house.
I was also a musician,
and I started
to play along with things,
and that was fun too.
And that was important,
because then I could actually
enter the music and find
a place to figure out
how I can actually get
into the space of it, which
has been a recurring
question for me as a writer.
How can I do it and
how can we all do it?
And then, at a
certain point somebody
handed me a jazz record when I
was a teenager, a Miles Davis
record.
A family friend said, I
think you might like this.
And that started a
long interest in jazz.
I went to a university that
had a great radio station.
And going to the
radio station which
had a great collection
of-- this was in 1985,
when I started college.
And they had a really big
collection of records,
particularly jazz records.
And that was my first
experience of the internet.
I like to ask people, what
was your first experience
of the internet before
there was an internet?
AARON ZEMACH: Oh, sure.
Of the social internet.
BEN RATLIFF: Of the
idea of muchness,
the idea of everythingness,
before there was an internet.
So here was the great matrix.
Here was the great
body of knowledge.
So where do I start?
I just start with what I know.
So I found my way to what I
knew, the records that I knew.
And then I thought, OK,
well what led to this?
I know this one record
by John Coltrane.
What created this record?
What led to this record?
And so then you go backwards.
So I learned a lot
about music that way.
And also I was a writer and
thought of myself as a writer.
And so it just sort
of became inevitable
that I'd be writing about music.
AARON ZEMACH: Uh-huh, great.
So you sort of
talked about the way
that you're always finding
new ways to listen to music
and get into music.
And one of the
premises of this book
is that a lot of the
ways that we typically
think about listening to
music don't suit us very well
in this age of the cloud
where we have infinite access
to all music at all times.
So what are the ways that you
feel people typically listen
to music, or the framework
that they think about music in?
BEN RATLIFF: Well,
this is anecdotal.
But I do find that in
the 10 years since--
let's say in the 10
years since Spotify,
and in the greater
amount of time
since, getting music
easily or for free
or whatever from the
internet has become
a normal practice in life.
I find that a lot of people
are faced with a choice.
And they might not even
know that it's a choice,
but it is a choice.
And the choice is either
kind of like bottomless--
I guess like an
infinite shallowness,
or a bottomless comfort zone.
Because by the time you become
a kind of engaged listener,
or somebody who likes
music, you sort of
have an idea of what
it is that you like.
And what the internet offers
you is the possibility
of being able to
listen to a larger
circle of what it is that you
like forever until you die.
[LAUGHTER]
And it's not as narrow
as it used to be.
It's much larger.
But it's basically related
to your self-definition
as a listener.
Or you can do
something else, which
is to be a little more
active and to think
of all that you have access to.
We have access to--
it's not everything.
In fact, it's not
everything, not even close.
But there's so much of it that
it can feel like everything.
And so what are we
going to do about it?
How are we going to
access what we don't know?
How are we going to walk
toward what we don't know?
Which to me feels
like the challenge,
I guess, but also the gift.
Because I lived half my
life before the internet,
before the internet
became popularly used,
I guess I still think
in terms of libraries,
of physical libraries.
That's my metaphor.
It's hard to shake it.
And so often, in
the conversations
that I often have with
people about music today--
what do you like,
what do you listen to,
how do you find new music?
The word overwhelmed
comes up often.
And so often that in fact,
it's become a kind of cliche.
People just don't even know
how to express their feeling
and they reach for
that word, overwhelmed.
So then I think
OK, well so, that's
funny, because let's say
you walk into a really
fantastic library, like a great
institutional library, the New
York Public Library, or
the one up at Columbia,
or the one down at NYU.
When you go in there,
especially if you
can sort of get a
sense of the stacks
and have a sense of how big
it is, is the first thing
you think oh, overwhelmed,
like I'll never have time
to read all this shit.
[LAUGHTER]
Or do you or do you think
something on the order of, wow?
It kind of makes me
feel good that there's
been all this human thought.
And I wonder how I can start
from what I know and find
reasons to get back
into those other rooms,
those other shelves, that as of
yet, I have no reason to go to?
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah.
So I wrote down some
of the examples.
So the book is a
series of essays,
I should say, about some
of these different methods
to try to unlock some
of the aspects of music.
I wrote down examples of
some of the chapters, things
like repetition, slowness,
speed, to sadness or intimacy.
So there's sort of this
wide range of different ways
that you talk about being
able to listen to music.
When you were thinking
about this book,
how did you come up with
those different ways?
Are these the ways that you
discovered that you naturally
listen to music?
Or are there other ways
that didn't get included?
Where did those
categories come from?
BEN RATLIFF: Sure.
Well, I'll just
tell you quickly why
this book and the structure
of it and whatever.
I started thinking about
this about five years ago.
I was a music critic
for a newspaper,
for "The New York
Times" for 20 years.
And I started thinking about
the music appreciation movement
in this country, which is
sort of like late 1800s
to about 1960.
A lot of people sort
of like me, often they
were newspaper writers,
would write books
for the general readership
that were sort of saying, oh,
so you want to know about music?
You want to feel you know
something about music?
Well here's some keys
to figuring it out.
And almost always
these books were
about Western classical music.
And it was about what the
composer wanted you to know.
This is what rhythm is,
this is what harmony
is, this is what melody is,
and then on and on toward this
is so sonata form, this is
what an oratorio is, whatever.
And there are many
books like this.
And I was thinking, well,
what would that look like now?
What would a book like
that look like now?
First of all, it wouldn't be all
about European classical music,
because we know now that as
rich as that tradition is,
it's not everything.
It's one of many possible
things that we can listen to.
And also the big
thing that's changed
is that listeners have
become so much more powerful
in a way because of our access.
Access is power.
So I thought, well, it would
be interesting to write
a book that was much more from
the listener point of view
rather than from the
composer point of view.
So at the same time,
I was listening
to a James Brown record a
lot called "Ain't It Funky."
And there's a seven minute song
on it called "Ain't It Funky."
And it's really repetitious,
and the repetition of it
is what's great about it.
And repetition is just such
an interesting subject.
And plenty of people
have written about it.
There are a number of really
good songs called "Repetition."
And so I thought, OK,
well, this is a great place
to start a book, writing
about repetition.
So if you write about James
Brown's kind of repetition,
then it only makes
sense to write
but Steve Reich's
kind of repetition
and Chic's kind of
repetition and repetition
in more top 40 music,
Rihanna or whatever.
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah, I wrote
down one of my favorite examples
was in like one paragraph,
you talk about Benny Goodman's
"Sing Sing Sing,"
and also Kesha's
"We R Who We R" as two
examples as ways to--
BEN RATLIFF: Well, I guess the
stealth argument of the book
is keep your receptors open.
Listen to everything.
Perhaps it doesn't
work for everybody.
I understand that.
And perhaps that in
fact, for many people,
the idea of listening
to a playlist where
the musical tradition
in that playlist
changes radically
every five minutes
might be annoying or
disturbing for some listeners.
I understand that.
But I guess I have
a baseline idea
that there's a sort of
virtue in listening broadly.
There's a virtue in keeping
your receptors open.
There's a virtue in being
able to move forward
in the world with what you
know, but be open to things
that you do not recognize,
and listen to it
and ask the question,
what's my way in?
How can I make use
of this and how can I
feel that it is also about me?
AARON ZEMACH: So if you're a
person who's sort of interested
in gaining that broad-- you want
to broaden your musical atlas--
I know you don't like
the term genre very much,
so I'm trying to avoid
that specifically.
Maybe you'll have
to get back to that.
If you want to broaden those
musical qualities that you're
listening to and you have
access to this seemingly
infinite music
library, what would you
recommend as a first
step to start trying
to broaden from where you are?
BEN RATLIFF: OK, so here's where
my talk becomes maybe tricky,
or it might sound evasive.
I tried hard not to talk
about platforms in this book.
In other words,
this isn't a book
about how to find all the
music that might inspire
you or enlarge you or whatever.
It's more about suggesting ways
of staying open, suggesting
ways of creating your own
little through lines for music.
And I do believe in
happenstance and dumb luck.
Music is sort of coming at
us from everywhere now--
in shops, in waiting rooms,
online, and of course,
in the streets.
Especially if we enter a
neighborhood that we're not
that familiar with,
or if we go to a place
that we've never been to before,
or a city that we don't know
that well, whatever,
we can hear music
that we've never
confronted before.
It's easy.
It can happen all the time.
So then for instance,
there's a chapter
in here about-- so
repetition is chapter one.
The other chapters
as you said include--
there's one about
loudness, there's
one about quietness,
and so forth.
Until by the end
of the book, I'm
talking about categories
that only I have thought of
and are only particular to me.
And these are just
suggested ways.
The point is I want to
give this to readers
and they can take it in
a direction they want.
But there's for instance,
a chapter in here
about a certain kind of repeat,
the way sometimes a note
is repeated in a piece
of music, stubbornly.
Not a structure of repetition,
but just one, a singer
or an instrumentalist
or whatever,
repeating one note over and
over and over stubbornly
for an effect.
Rock and roll fans
will recognize
that in the guitar solo in
"Cinnamon Girl" by Neil Young.
For some reason
and rock and roll,
it's a big thing when it's done.
"Cinnamon Girl" is known as--
that's the song where
the guy plays a solo
and it's just one
note over and over.
Isn't that weird?
And it is kind of
weird, and it's great.
But in other kinds of
music it's really common,
it's really routine.
In Afro-Latin music,
it's just normal.
More and more in
hip hop, it's kind
of normal, what people
maybe describe pejoratively
as monotone rap.
That's a device,
that's an effect.
And often the
rappers aren't just
hitting the same exact
note over and over,
but a very general
area around a note.
So the point is, we
can all encounter
examples of this,
wherever we go,
and think about
music in that way.
And by doing so,
the idea of genre
sort of goes out the window.
And I find that
freeing, or at least
it creates a possibility
for knowing about more,
rather than knowing about less.
AARON ZEMACH: Sure.
So now that you've sort
of formalized in a sense
these different
categories in this book,
do you find that it's affected
the way, when you start
listening to a new album
or go to a concert,
is it affecting the way that
you're listening to music?
BEN RATLIFF: Yeah, sure.
Because as a critic,
I think what I always
did was I would listen to a
piece of music and think OK,
so what is the essential
thing going on here?
Such that if you took
that essential bit out,
it just wouldn't be as
special, or the whole thing
would sort of fall apart.
What is the essential
thing, whether it's
a certain kind of technique
or a certain kind of mood,
or a certain kind of
structure or whatever,
what is that thing that
makes this piece of music
extraordinary?
And just to give you
an example, right now
I read "The New York
Times" every morning.
I'm a subscriber and I
read the print version,
because I like the idea that
by scanning across the pages,
I'm going to encounter something
that I don't know about
by happenstance.
I like that.
And over the past few
months, every time
I read the paper
when I'm done, I
want to put my head in a toilet.
I really feel hopeless.
But I've been listening to
a record now these days.
And I realize,
this is the record
that makes me want to take
my head out of the toilet.
And it's called "Coltrane
Plays the Blues."
It's a record by John
Coltrane, the jazz saxophonist.
It's not like one of
his most famous records.
It's from 1960, about.
Every track uses the blues
form, blues structure,
but they're original blues, I
think all written by Coltrane.
Why do I like it?
What is the essential
thing about it?
It's because this record
expresses certainty.
It is completely present.
There are these four people in
a band making music in a room.
And you feel the
dimensions of that room,
because sometimes Coltrane
moves his saxophone away
from the microphone and
you feel a sense of space,
where they're making the music.
You feel a sense of urgency
in what they're doing,
and also a sense
of the long game.
There's urgency and wisdom.
Like they're going
to put everything
they have into this moment
and be fully present,
and yet they are able to see
rather far into the future.
And that's how I want
to feel right now.
[CHUCKLES] I want to see beyond
what's going on right now.
I want to be able
to see beyond that.
And I want to feel urgent
and present and alive.
So that's what I'm
listening for at the moment.
I'm listening for that
feeling specifically
as I move through life.
That could be chapter number 21.
AARON ZEMACH: It feels
like we kind of just
watched you construct review
for "Coltrane Plays the Blues"
up here on stage.
As you were thinking of
writing a piece of criticism
or a review, is that sort of
the process you go through
of listening,
finding that thing,
and translating it to the page?
BEN RATLIFF: Yes.
I try to find the one
essential thing that
for me, makes something
special, and then really bear
down hard on it and describe
it as well as I can, almost
in a ritual sense, which sort
of mirrors the ritual going on
in the music and honors it.
Yes, and so if I can put
my finger on that one
essential thing in the music
that makes it powerful,
special, whatever, describe
it well, and really get
going, then in the best sense,
in the best possible situation,
something of the
essence of that music
can actually sort of
rise up out of the text.
[LAUGHS] I know it
sounds mystical,
but otherwise you're
just describing music,
or you're evaluating something,
thumbs up or thumbs down,
which feels sort
of limited to me.
AARON ZEMACH: Sure.
So we're going to open it up
to questions from the audience
in just a minute.
So if you have a question,
we have microphones
on either side of the stage.
You can go line up.
Before that, kind of
off of that question,
I'm interested if anyone here in
the audience or watching later
is interested in starting
a career in music
journalism or music
criticism, what
would you recommend to someone
who is just starting out?
BEN RATLIFF: Well,
there are many more
places to write about music now
than there were when I started,
say, 25 years ago.
And that's great.
They don't all pay
very well or at all,
but when you're starting, you
don't need to worry about that.
The point is, I think it's
important to know the identity
and character of these different
publications or websites
or whatever, try
to figure out some
that you really identify with
that you feel strongly about.
And if you start to
think, I'd really
like to see my
name there, I would
be good with that if I
could see my name in there,
I'd be really proud of that,
move toward that place.
It might take
several steps and it
might take some months or
a year, but move toward it.
Start thinking in terms of what
kinds of writing do they use?
What kinds of
writing can they use?
writing do they want?
Start writing that way.
That's how to get involved.
And then from there, you can go
in whatever direction you want.
AARON ZEMACH: Go straight
to "The New York Times."
BEN RATLIFF: Straight-- yeah.
AARON ZEMACH: So we have some
questions from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, hi.
So I think it's pretty
obvious that the internet has
changed the music industry.
But given that you've
been following music
both before and
after the internet,
do you think the internet
has changed music itself.
And if so, how?
BEN RATLIFF: Yeah, I do.
I think in a way that punk was
a funny forecast of internet era
music, because the whole
point was to do it cheaply.
And it was like an ethic
of doing it cheaply,
and a value of doing it cheaply.
And now of course, everybody's
making music on their own,
because we've got the tools.
It's very easy to make a
good record in your room.
And I suppose there's
the ease of it,
which means there's a whole
lot more music appearing.
And also I do think that
there's a certain flattening
of the hierarchy of influences.
In the old days, if you were
a certain kind of songwriter
or musician, there were--
I'm trying to think
of concrete examples
so this doesn't
sound so abstract.
But for instance, if you were
a jazz musician in the '80s,
it was very important for you
to know about Coltrane and Miles
Davis and Charlie Parker,
but probably not so important
for you to know
about Sidney Bechet
and what happened
before the '40s,
and not so important for you to
know about free improvisation.
Because that stuff just wasn't
quite as easy to come by.
It wasn't quite as plentiful
and easy to come by.
But now the internet made
everything equally accessible.
So that became the big change.
You found greater numbers
of many, many more kinds
of influences on each
individual artist,
and used in unexpected ways.
In the '90s, it still felt
unusual to hear a Timbaland
production and to hear the
startling sounds in it that
came from a totally
different musical tradition.
It was still startling
to hear a DJ mix that
might move from current hip
hop to Jamaican dance hall
to some kind of 20th century
classical music, whatever.
Now it's almost expected,
it's so easy to do.
So those are some of
the changes, I think.
AUDIENCE: So in your
Coltrane example,
you talked about Coltrane
walking away from the mic
and it changes the sound.
Do you ever go into a song and
listen to a song or music piece
from the standpoint of
the recording engineering?
That changes everything, right?
We've gone from this
analog technology where
you can get these
warm distorted pieces
to this digital technology
where that's replicated
or not quite the same.
So one of the things we've
kind of lost in this transition
to digital, perhaps, are
really good liner notes.
And you don't always see who
the recording engineer was,
but you give a musician the same
room and the same instruments,
but a different
recording engineer.
And it's going to have
a different sound.
So how often do you go
into looking at music
from the recorded sound?
BEN RATLIFF: More
and more, actually.
Yeah, it makes a difference.
The engineer/producer,
those roles
are sometimes
interchangeable, they're
sometimes the same thing.
Yeah, it makes a big difference.
A piece of recorded music
isn't just a reference.
It isn't just a
document of something
that happened in a certain
time at a certain place.
It's evidence of
a physical space.
And especially when live
musicians are involved.
But even in electronic
music, a physical space
can be suggested.
And yeah, I'm just
saying yes, yes, yes.
But yeah, and the work of
engineers and producers
has very much to do with this,
I think, of the suggestion
of music as a physical space.
AUDIENCE: So in the answer
to your previous question,
you referenced the punk
movement and doing it cheaply.
But more and more people
are working at home now.
And you find many great
musicians are really
poor engineers.
So we've gone from these big
halls, Abbey Road, real world
studios, to people making
music in their bedrooms.
How do you think that has
affected the recorded medium
that we hear nowadays?
BEN RATLIFF: I don't think that
it's made us worse listeners.
I have great faith in listeners.
I have great faith
in listeners' ability
to accept music, either
as the simple thing,
a certain document of
what a musician is doing
at a certain place and
time, versus something
bigger, something
that does suggest
something greater, an
environment, a moment
in history, whatever.
There's so much variation
in what can happen.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BEN RATLIFF: Yeah, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi
BEN RATLIFF: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I really
loved what you
were saying about getting
outside of our music comfort
zone and sort of walking the
streets in new neighborhoods.
Yet I feel this undeniable
gravitational pull
to my headphones at all times.
I feel like part of it's that we
sit in an open office culture,
and so just to concentrate.
But I find myself
even sometimes just,
it's like I reach for it
before I even think twice.
And I just love to
know your thoughts
on when headphones are a good
thing, when we should second
guess our headphones, and just
know your thoughts on that.
BEN RATLIFF: Yeah, that's
a subject that I've never
really dealt with in writing
that much, I think because I'm
afraid of leaning toward the
automatic response of take
your headphones
out of your ears,
listen to what's
going on around you!
Because that seems manifestly--
it's almost a truism that
taking your headphones out
of your ears is a good thing.
It increases your
spatial awareness.
It clues you into how
other people are talking.
It makes you more
sensitive to the world
around you, et cetera.
But I use headphones a lot.
And why is that?
Because I like the
sustained experience
of immersion in music.
We all listen to music more,
I think, than we used to.
There was a poll two years ago.
I think it was a Nielsen poll.
And I think another
polling group or research
group called Edison something
also did the same kind of poll.
And they both came up with
the same basic answer,
which is that most
Americans listen
to music for four hours a day.
And that's really a lot.
And I imagine that a lot of that
is probably done on headphones.
And yeah, we do live more
individualized lives.
We are more in tune with
our particular streams
of information or culture.
I suppose it's part of
how we're surviving.
It could be that.
AUDIENCE: When you think
about the sort of social
versus solo as a
platform for listening,
I haven't read your book yet,
but I absolutely will now.
Is that something that
you discuss and headphones
playing a role in that solo
versus social experience
listening to music?
BEN RATLIFF: It is not
something I discuss in the book,
and I'd really like to discuss
it at some point in the future.
Because it's really interesting.
If you think about what
music is for originally,
like way, way, way
back, it's something
that was done with people.
Either you were making
music with other people,
or it had something to do
with the church, or whatever.
So the experience of
music totally solo,
which is just so
common, is a new thing.
I do it every day.
But I don't talk about
platforms in the book.
But I will say that my
current sort of filter,
the thing that I trust more than
anything else to deliver music
to me, is not an algorithm
but an internet radio
station called NTS
that's based in London.
And to me, it is sort of like
my dream of musical breadth
with very little sense
of a corporate entity
trying to say we're
this radio station,
we're the kind of
radio station that
gives you this, listen to us!
There's very little of that.
There's no commercials,
there's nol nothing.
It's just 24/7 DJs
who really know
what they're doing,
and presenting
all kinds of different music.
So I listen to that
every morning for an hour
and I'm good.
But I do that with
headphones, so it's
a very immersive experience.
That seems to be what I want.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
BEN RATLIFF: Hi
AUDIENCE: I got a little
bit late to this talk,
so I don't know if you
already touched this, so
apologies if you did.
So I find myself listening to
a lot of music from '60s, '70s,
'80s.
And as you were
saying earlier, when
I look at the album of the year
of like "NME," "Pitchfork,"
any publication,
I get really sad.
I try to give it a go and
it doesn't really work out.
So it just seems
like I'm not really
into music that people are
making these days, or not
so much.
So my question to you is, do
you feel like music distribution
platforms like Spotify
who will play music,
do feel like that
they devalue music?
BEN RATLIFF: Interesting.
So you're saying that music from
the '60s was better than music
now.
And that part of what has led
to that problem is Spotify.
AUDIENCE: A
paradigmatic example is
that for example, the other
day I had never listened to it,
but I started listening to
an album from Black Sabbath.
BEN RATLIFF: Which one?
AUDIENCE: I'm
trying to remember.
Master--
BEN RATLIFF:
"Master of Reality."
AUDIENCE: Yes.
"Master of Reality,"
because I got this last song
and I was like, yeah,
this is really cool stuff.
And I could see myself before
music was so easy for me
to just open
Spotify and hit play
and it was playing for me,
even in the times of Napster,
I would have to actually
go have the effort
to download the album.
And it would be
just sitting there
and I could just
open the folder,
so I had to go through that.
But what happens now is that
I go, I give it a few plays,
I listen to the record for--
I don't know, not
even a week, maybe.
And I'm already done with it.
And I just go fast forward.
Whereas before, I think
I would just maybe
ruminate a little bit more.
BEN RATLIFF: You're
suggesting that it's not even
the music's fault.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
That's my question,
like do you think
that the platforms
devalue music?
Do you think that
because it's so easy
to reach that artists
will slack off
or it will be so easy for people
to listen to other artists
so they would just
not put as much effort
into making nice melodies?
BEN RATLIFF: I think
it can de-value,
that there can be some
devaluing going on, yes.
When I was a
teenager, I would have
to go great distances to find
a certain kind of record.
And the journey that
I took to do it,
whether it was bicycling
or taking a bus
or going to another
city or asking somebody
to mail me a copy or whatever,
the effort expended seemingly
to me added value to the
music once it finally arrived
and I put it on the thing.
And that created
more value, sure.
A colleague of mine
once said to me,
I think I was telling this
colleague that same exact story
or whatever.
And he said oh, so
then you'd rather
go get water from a well
every day, like [GRUNTS],
drag it all the way into your
house maybe several times
a day?
You'd prefer that than
just turning on the tap?
And no, I wouldn't prefer.
I would prefer to
turn on the tap.
I think that as long as
you are aware of how easy
it is, as long as you really
are aware of how easy it
is to just press one button
and immediately you've
got Beach House or
whatever, then that helps.
But there's another question.
It sounds like you're
saying that music
from before had more value.
AUDIENCE: To me it did.
The other time I
saw a picture where
it had the lyrics from
a Led Zeppelin song
compared to lyrics from I don't
know, a nowadays indie artist,
I couldn't remember who he was.
And the Led Zeppelin ones
were like so ordinated,
it was so masterfully crafted.
Like Steely Dan, I was
listening to it the other day.
And they were such
good tunes, that you
could see that they had
been worked and reworked
and reworked.
And I don't see anyone
doing that nowadays.
I don't know if it's
because it pays less,
it's not as rewarding.
I don't know if
it's because people
are just not into that anymore.
I'm kind of trying
to look for an answer
to why I like that stuff
before, and it's just nowadays
nothing really moves me like--
BEN RATLIFF: I'm not
convinced by that argument.
I do think that there's
a lot of new music
that is every bit as
exciting as music that
was made in the '60s and '70s.
Sometimes what is new about
it, is often the question.
And sometimes the ways
that it is new are just,
they're smaller ways.
But I think that Salon's
record is particularly good.
I think the new record by Cass
McCombs is particularly good.
I think that there's
plenty of people making
music that has lots of stuff
going on, lots of thought,
lots of--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Maybe then another
question would be,
why is it not that mainstream?
But maybe I think someone
else wants to make question,
so I'll probably cut it here.
But thanks.
BEN RATLIFF: Sure.
There is another way of
thinking about it too.
There's a writer named Marc
Fisher who died last month.
And he was a British
Marxist, sort
of cyberpunk-influenced
academic music obsessive writer.
And he wrote a lot
about music, a lot of it
on a blog in the
aughts called K-Punk.
And his theory was
that we live in a time
where there's no
more originality
and it's all stopped.
And the reason for that has to
do with, he blamed capitalism.
Marc Fisher said
that it's now easier
to imagine the end of
the world than to imagine
the end of capitalism.
And so he talked about music
with a sense of great loss,
it's so much harder now to
imagine the future, a future.
I'm not nearly that doctrinaire.
And I believe that in the
way we listen to music now,
we are still
participating in music
in lots of different ways.
Even when we're listening
to something on SoundCloud
you know and somebody will put
a little comment in somewhere
along the way, and the
comment will be like ooh,
or I love that part right there.
This is part of how we interact.
And also, of course,
going to live performances
and taking part, participating
in the culture around music.
This is all still going on.
All of this suggests
that music has a future
and that participation
has a future.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm curious about your
ideas on the validity
of not liking something.
As a music critic or
just as a consumer,
what happens when you
just listen to something
and you don't like it?
Do you think it's on your
part to try harder to like it?
Or do you think
maybe at some point
you could just give up and be
like, I just don't like it?
BEN RATLIFF: Yep,
you can give up.
I think you can give up.
But I think that if
you can be specific
about what you're
giving up, and maybe
if you can accept
the possibility
that that particular music
that you decided is no good,
that particular recording,
song, artist, whatever,
may come from a
tradition that has
things that will be
really meaningful to you,
that you might like.
I think that's good.
I guess what I don't like is,
when people these days say,
I'm the kind of person who--
like, my blood freezes.
I'm the kind of person who just
doesn't like such and such.
And usually it's a big
thing, it's a big thought,
it's a big area, it's an entire
tradition of music or whatever.
I just think, ugh.
What a loss, what a loss.
So you don't like this
one techno record.
Does that mean
that all techno is
going to be terrible for you?
Probably not.
So maintain curiosity
is all I'm into.
But that's what I'm into.
But there's plenty of
things that I can't stand.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was kind of curious
if you ever had to review
an album that maybe
everybody likes but you're
just like, I can't stand it.
At what point can you just be
like, just hand off to somebody
else?
BEN RATLIFF: Yeah.
Often I was able to hand
it off to somebody else.
And sometimes I had
to go through with it,
and really felt like an alien.
And I can't think of a
single example of these.
But yeah, I had definitely
had that experience for sure.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AARON ZEMACH: We've got time for
one more question really quick.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Do you think there
is any wrong way
to recommend music to people?
BEN RATLIFF: Do I think
there's a wrong way
to recommend music to people?
I have kind of a grudge
against algorithms.
And here's why.
Algorithms, they will exist.
They will continue to
get better and better.
They're not going away.
So I feel fine in saying that
I have a grudge against them.
And sometimes
they're useful too,
because they will
put in front of you
a song that you've
never heard before.
There's a value to that.
That song is probably
related to things
you already know,
and is probably
being put in front of you
so as to make you feel
comfortable-- comforted, even.
And to me, it feels like--
well, what I've learned
from watching stalker movies
and also from having worked as
a music critic at The New York
Times" and having worked
with music publicists
is that I don't trust
people who come to me
and say, I know you're
going to like this,
because I know about you and
I'm anticipating your desires.
If they love me as a human
being and they say that,
there's nothing better.
But if they're saying that for
professional or financial gain,
I don't trust them for a second.
I don't know.
I guess my advice to people
is to use algorithms,
but know that they're faulty.
Know that they're limited.
Know that they don't
really know what you're
going to be thinking tomorrow.
They can't.
They're predicated entirely
on who you were yesterday.
To try to imagine new
things, new ways of listening
that you haven't done
up to this point,
that's imagining a future.
That's what being able
to imagine a future is.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AARON ZEMACH: I wish we
could stick around and talk
about music all day, but we've
got to wrap up, unfortunately.
We have "Every
Song Ever" for sale
in the back of the
room afterwards.
And I'd like to thank Ben once
again for coming to Google.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]